jubilance and excitement as tourists and
international passengers touched down in
australia after almost two years of
border closures picking up my best
friend um i haven't seen him since 2018
and he made it back just in time for my
wedding in four days i'm really excited
actually yes
um i'm going to see my friends for the
first time in the since five years that
last was here yeah surreal it doesn't
feel
quite real like it feels a bit bizarre
it wasn't just tourists arriving but
families reuniting
over the last two years australia has
pursued a tough zero covert 19 strategy
quarantine restrictions have also been
in place posing a major hurdle for
australian citizens wanting to return i
didn't know flights would potentially be
delayed because of what's going on
overseas but and there are very few
repatriation flights really even for
londoners it was like 55 000 australians
wanted to come home and there's three
flights a month so you know it was
pretty grim
but it's just good to see my sister
again and i can't wait to go see mum and
dad now because i've been worrying about
them for two years
australia has one of the highest
immunisation rates in the world with
more than 90 of people over 16 fully
vaccinated
tourists coming here must be double
vaccinated or have a medical exemption
more than 1 million tourist visas have
been issued for arrival this month
tourism was one of the fastest growing
sectors in australia's economy before
the pandemic in 2019 it contributed
around 30 billion dollars but the border
closures earned the nation the
reputation as fortress australia and
tourism groups know they've got a big
job on their hands to convince tourists
to return
there's a huge job ahead of us we have
had an incredible disruption to our
industry no international visitors great
disruption to the domestic market as
well for australia that meant we lost
about 80 billion dollars worth of
international revenue along and to put
it all back together it's a complex
machine our industry you have to get
your airlines back in the air at the
airports they're ready
but not every state in australia is
welcoming arrivals western australia has
been closed to both international
travelers and had quarantined
restrictions in place for vaccinated
australian citizens for most of the
pandemic it will eventually open its
borders in march
sarah clark al jazeera brisbane
australia